hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alva and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna talk about a movie today
called bumblebee yo bumblebee is a film
that you already know what it's about it
takes place in the 80s it's a prequel to
the Transformers movies you guys already
know that okay give you a whole plot
description here before we go into this
though I wanted to give a special thank
you to all you beautiful sons of
bumblebee words out there who followed
us on the Stardust app over at the
Stardust app we do 30 second reaction
reviews for any film TV show or trailer
it's a total blast we even do a lot of
micro sketches on there we post daily
there's a lot of big youtubers on there
but we're the best ones putting that out
there right now know the app and follow
us a day free to download free to use
let's get to this review so for anyone
who knows me they know I don't like any
Transformers movies I don't even like
the first one which is the kind of one
that most people say really I'm just
never been a fan they're all boring as
hell than me John is a huge enthusiast
of the movies I don't know why it's been
the only film franchise we've ever
disagreed on entirely John what did you
think of bumblebee I think it's the
worst Transformers movie it destroyed
everything I love about these films I
don't get how you can be a Transformers
fan and like this movie yeah this film's
delightful it's amazing I really really
really enjoyed it man I had a great time
when I was watching it it's not only
great because of the fact that it's so
much better than the other films that
came before it it's genuinely a great
film like the big discussion I kept
having with everyone out the theaters
like I know I like it a lot too I love
it only because of the fact that it's
better at night like if I hadn't seen
the other Transformers films I would
like it just as much oh yeah totally I
mean I think this film stands on its own
a hundred percent like whether or not
you feel any type of way about the other
Transformers films this film is
delightful on its own and while I'm not
perhaps as enthusiastic about it as you
are I still really liked it a lot and it
yeah definitely surprised me in a lot of
very pleasant ways I've only seen four
episodes of the Transformers cartoon and
in the trailers they they show footage
that there's gonna be
some sequences you see on Cybertron and
when you have those moments it's not
most of the film when you have those
it's like straight out of the cartoon
and it's so satisfiying man it's really
satisfying but as the actual plot goes
on as the actual journey continues you
know with Hailee Steinfeld being this
girl who all she really wants is an
automobile for herself and then she gets
this bug it's a beam bumblebee and you
get this like transformers meets Iron
Giant kind of film it really exceeds in
that department because what really
astounded me is how character-driven
this film managed to be it has it kind
of an interesting structure because in
the first half of the movie let's check
in with bumblebee in Hailee Steinfeld
and have their little cute journey
progressing and then let's cut to the
military let's cut to you know some you
know there's a big action stakes that
are coming soon so the Decepticons and
what they're playing yeah gonna be as
they pursue the movie but then in the
second half of act 2 you kind of ignore
all that and you're really just hanging
out with bumblebee and Hailee Steinfeld
yeah and they're great together I don't
know what Hailee Steinfeld was exactly
playing off of when she had to do this
movie but she gives an astounding
performance she carries this film she's
great I fell in love with her in this
movie yeah she's definitely really good
and she's able to elevate some of the
lesser dialogue even towards the
beginning of the film and stuff like
that because you know her character a
big part of it is that she is grieving
for her father and that's a big element
to the movie as well that makes it very
personal that she plays really really
well you know very lived-in it's the
first Transformers movie where I really
care about not just yeah anything
bumblebee is a real character in this
movie without spoiling too much I was
told beforehand bumblebee has a voice
and you see how he loses his voice I was
told that and I didn't really feel like
do to spoil the move for me I don't know
if you guys are feeling that way that I
related that information to you one of
the only jarring things about the movie
to me when I when I looked back on it
cuz the movie is so good in the moment
of what's happening is the bumblebee
prior to losing his voice is a totally
different bumblebee the bumblebee with
voice is a badass warrior soldier yeah
yeah and then when he loses his voice
it's the cute child bumble beat that you
see in the trailers and
that is kind of portrayed in the
Transformers movie oh yeah that is like
when he loses his voice he also loses
his memory and so half the movie is
about him kind of being Jason Bourne
almost in a very Bobby I did yeah
exactly a very cuddly kind of way as he
sort of learns about his surroundings
fresh and then has to kind of figure out
what he's doing on earth in the first
place and why these Decepticons are here
he's kind of a nervous animal about it
yeah he does have that skittish almost
like dog or cat like daddy where he's
like adorable but also really huge
incapable of destruction I know a lot of
people already love bumblebee and that's
why they got this bumblebee spin-off but
I in this movie was time I'm like okay
I'm on the bumblebee hide for a little
making-of featurette is how much they
wanted to make it so that bumblebee
could emot-- and they said something
very specific about the eyes yeah
removing all like the different cogs and
gears and things that get in the way of
emotion he also given these little ear
things - yeah and those really help to
make his body language and his emotions
stand out and I'll still say that even
though this is much more of a character
piece and a more of like a kind of a
family film because you really get to
spend time with Hailee Steinfeld's
family as well they're more than just
background characters like they actually
get to be characters that do stuff in
the movie well yeah those are trying to
be a Steven Spielberg John Hughes movie
at the same time as it's being a
Transformers movie I think it succeeds
at that I would say for the most part it
does I do there there were times when I
personally for my own taste felt it to
be a bit intrusive because I was just
like no like I I get it it's the
eighties you don't need to play another
song right away I understand but they do
a very good job of making it feel
authentically like yours I like to be
reminded of the era as much as possible
I love the 80s I get it was born right
after that
everyone's watching Alf I understand
everybody talks like they're in an 80s
movie I understand well I mean speaking
of which I laughed a lot in this movie I
laughed a lot not in like weird Michael
Bay humor laughing there's some
intentional comedy in here that really
gets you going from bubble beam Hailee
Steinfeld John Cena in this movies the
main military guy you focus on it's
weird as when he was doing serious parts
in this movie
it seemed laughable but when he was
doing the scenes where he's supposed to
be funny he's brilliant yeah he had the
biggest late it's a it's an intentional
laugh yeah everybody knows if you've
seen the movie you'll know what joke I'm
talking about yeah something that we're
all thinking yeah actually helps the
movie the joke itself and I think the
only real cheesy element that I felt
could have been written better was the
military people overall they were really
written in like the most cliche military
aspect that felt like so out of a
cartoon it was kind of distracting to me
and especially since we like the other
transformer souls are so military heavy
and this wasn't like serious stuff but
it was still like really cheesy to me I
think that's the biggest teetering point
for me on this movie is just the
cartoonish Ness overall because they
think it is appropriate but especially
with the way movies like this evolved
and military sequences are so tactical
and realistic now there are times when
it doesn't quite mesh and some things
feel a little out of place amid the
cartoon enos yeah and then when the
movie checks itself and goes oh yeah
we're a cartoon then everything gets
back together
yeah then with you or Travis tonight
having his old background in animation
he has a here's a very poetic
storytelling way about it there were
certain elements especially in the
finale with arts that kind of felt a
little corny to me but because of his
poetic storytelling I was like Baskar it
more for it you'll know what I'm talking
about when you see the movie that deal
with Hailee Steinfeld and but I like all
those omens and the other cool thing too
that I was more surprised by than
anything else is the action is directed
totally different than the Michael Bay
phones but the action is so great in
this movie yeah it's great action
sequences I felt like we were in a
theater with a lot of people who are a
little bit like all right let's see if
this changes the way the Transformers
movies are done because when the movie
started no one was like wow yeah it
wasn't it wasn't that kind of crowd but
by the time you get to the finale with
like the big action sequences that are
obviously gonna happen that are teased
in the trailers and stuff
people applauded it a couple of moments
there's one very specific moment that's
so cleverly done that people had to clap
and then by the time the credits rolled
everyone applauded too you know and I
know I saw some people crying by the end
of this movie as well I personally did
it but I saw some people who were really
touched by the arcs in this movie yeah
you grew up a loving Transformers and
they
back to the generation 1 designs for
this issue so if you have a lot of
transformers and nostalgia I got imagine
that you'll be moved just by the fact
that they got this right and it has a
heart inside of it rather than yeah this
sort of cynical and you know Sueno
Michael Behe take on it and yeah the the
emotional story at the core of the movie
well I thought it started out kind of
thin really develops over the course to
where by the end you're very affected
yeah man when you get to the finale
fights it's not like the other
Transformers movies really like once
this gonna end
and who is he it's like there's so much
emotional stakes even the villain
transformers the Decepticons that are
featured in here have personalities so
the Transformers actually feel like
characters this time and then you start
to think oh I get how this could work in
the future even just on Cybertron yeah I
was very enthusiastic over the fact that
the Transformers actually felt like
characters and not weird CGI looking
things that have some dialogue here or
there I mean I get a headache every time
a new one shows I'm gonna have to try
and keep track of who you are like I
have this thing personalities they had
personalities yeah yeah so by the time
you get to the finale fight you're
really invested in the fight it's not
just oh my god once the CGI gonna end
you're actually invested in the
emotional stakes of what's going on I
felt like they course-corrected the [ __ ]
out of the Transformers franchise and
they've brought us a great movie that
has a lot of heart that I feel like
families can really go and enjoy this
movie like this is a family film that
also has the cool awesome elements that
you'd want every element of this movie
gets some kind of overhaul whether it's
a physical overhaul or a thematic
overhaul and yeah it seems like a very
nice way to proceed for the Transformers
films that could build some goodwill
yeah it's smart in the way it's done
because I think the marketing has
pitched this as a prequel I guess you
can if you need to but they really don't
do anything to make you go remember that
thing in transformers 1 this could be
the reboot they could just start fresh
from here if they want it you could do
this from here bumblebee in the first
transformers is gonna be like why is he
completely recommend this movie just for
the fact of a course correction alone I
recommend this like old-school
Transformers fans will be psyched
I bet kids I mean it might be a little
intense for little kids but I bet young
kids like kids are gonna look so much
adorableness that I think you'll and
patron the day shout-out to a man named
James Stegen before we wrap this video
up that's how you leave a tweet asking
like I don't understand how spin off
about the bumble bee could possibly be
interesting I'm telling you buddy it's
worth it all right I know you got your
brand-new car you're acting all cocky
Christmas is your favorite time of the
year you still get your cynical attitude
on about the Transformers films cut the
BS dude and get with the BP today buddy
it's telling you it's worth it you're
not jealous cuz your car doesn't
transform so this is really I was
waiting trying to contribute all right
guys well did you see bumblebee are you
excited for the future the Transformers
franchise have you given up on this
franchise entirely comment below and
comment subscribe to the react nation
click that notification bell check us
out the star to us at people free it
down for two years dude today